Oh
well in industrialized countries there's
no question that the encroachment of the
pharmaceutical industry and its
marketing practices has I think dilla t
really affected the kind of medical care
we get and the decisions that consumers
are making many countries Donal eyes
something we call DTC or
direct-to-consumer advertising the
United States does and what's happened
is that the pharmaceutical industry can
directly market its products to
consumers in until late 1990s the
pharmaceutical industry could only
market prescription drugs to healthcare
workers to physicians and then there was
a relaxing of those rules and they could
market their product directly to
consumers creating this clamor for the
latest brand name product which might
not even necessarily be better or safer
than the existing product on the market
what we see to is that because rd is so
expensive there are a whole bunch of
knee to drugs and that the
pharmaceutical industry is largely
engaged in producing drugs that will
come on the market to deal with the fact
that something's off patent it's going
to be cheap because it'll be generic so
we need something new and different
maybe minuscule e different from a
previous drug and I think the story of
prilosec and nexium is probably one of
the best stories you can tell about a
product that comes on the market really
not any markedly different from the
first product but they can be sold at 10
times the cost of the first product
sometimes more then you've got the issue
of whether or not you control
pharmaceutical pricing that's a huge
problem in terms of access to medicines
that we do need access to and in many
countries there are government controls
over pharmaceutical pricing but in the
United States the drug industry's Lobby
has been so powerful that we don't see
those same controls over drug company
pricing we've had some efforts the VA
administration of course is one place
where we're able to see some measure of
control over the pricing of drugs and
the VA system actually is one of the
best systems that functions in our
country today
we'll all of our materials emphasize for
women the fact that commercial interests
are producing much of the written
material the electronic material the TV
shows that they see now that they can't
assume that they're getting unbiased
uncompromised information that conflicts
of interest exists everywhere so we say
learn the source of your information is
it a drug company producing the material
sometimes it's actually not bad
information but very often it's all
about minimizing the harms the risks and
maximizing the benefits and exaggerating
the benefits so you have to look deeper
beyond the sort of twenty second bullet
points you see even physicians are
inappropriately in influenced by
pharmaceutical advertising and
educational programming so you can't
always depend on your physician one
excellent example is the overuse of
statin drugs in women for primary
prevention of heart attacks things like
that that for secondary prevention we
have very good studies that show benefit
for women but not for primary prevention
so now women who simply have an elevated
cholesterol level no other problems are
told to go on statin drugs when in fact
in many cases is they stand to be hurt
more than helped and getting it the kind
of data that evidence-based folks have
produced those without conflicts of
interest these are physicians and
researchers whom we try to work closely
with getting at that information is
often hard because it doesn't make it
onto television it's certainly in the
medical literature but there's no PR
company getting that out to you the
public so we are a voice for those
sources of uncompromised information we
make sure it's in lei Leng gwa jande we
get it out in our website through our
blog we have a very popular blog our
bodies our blog that many women read
every day and we send our readers and
our hua our listeners to these other
sources of more dependable information
where there aren't conflicts of interest
and that's something every single woman
has to think about and be concerned
about is where is the conflict of
interest here am I getting information
that is truly not tainted by commercial
interests another excellent example of
where we saw this was in the recent new
mammography guidelines produced
the US Preventive Services Task Force
these are excellent guidelines those who
have a lot to lose if women under 50
don't get routine mammograms or if women
over 50 do it maybe a little less
frequently based upon their profile they
have a lot to lose those are the ones
critiquing this not the evidence-based
folks those without conflicts of
interest and there are many of them out
there have reviewed what the preventive
services task force is produced and
certainly our experts those for the
National Women's Health Network and
several other wonderful organizations
have gone to back and said these are
excellent guidelines we should be
following them it's not about denying
women care and by the way everyone
should understand that mammography is a
relatively weak tool for screening we
need better tools in the area of breast
cancer it's not like Pap tests where we
have an excellent screening tool for
cervical cancer we're not doing so well
in the area of breast cancer so there's
an area where you would have seen the
American Cancer Society you would have
seen some prominent folks in breast
cancer treatment and people who have
interest some in some in cases in the
equipment the mammography equipment
that's being sold they have financial
interests in it so of course they don't
want to see the business go down these
are things the public doesn't see very
easily